hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to mad meta meta full
conversion mod for amnesia I'm not off
to a good start in this one let's try it
anyway so thank you all so much for
being what am i doing the outro start
over
welcome to a full conversion mod for
amnesia I hope you enjoy this journey
because I think that this game or at
least based on the reset I seen is going
to provide an environment that is both
terrifying and terrifying and I'm always
exact I'm always missing if you got a
killer talk today I'm always eager to
try oh this is my final warning I know
about your illegal activities so what
what are you going to do about that
please be reasonable my reports about
your scandals are prepared to issue
daily press what do you know you are
just a foolish report
enough you leave me no other choice I
will go and tell the world about your
filthiness you're not going anywhere
Wow
hey Karen well he hit me with a piece of
ham how's the wettest thunk I've ever
heard unless I was my brain going every
what huge scandal of local Baron
canceled but it wouldn't even be in the
paper if it was canceled and what was my
mistake going to approach the crazy guy
who's probably killing millions to tell
him hey you better stop that before I
get captured and die horribly oh boy
where am I now
hello I saw Zhiming over there left man
huh
nothing I think it was something good
bye penumbra monsters who decided to see
me in the middle of the night when I'm
tied to the stable Oh
click the struggle oh I'm struggling
baby I'm click to release myself Oh once
again very wet splats going on here oh I
hope those are my intestines I just left
behind oh those aren't my internal
organs well alright then this is off to
a gracious start so meta is a full
conversion mod by the bad but I am
having so much trouble today it is very
early morning but this is by the same
guy that made Destiny's rebellion and if
you've watched my Destiny's rebellion
scene or haven't already go watch it now
because it's a fantastic custom story
about nine parts long that proves that
you can have a lot of fun while also
getting the pants scared off of you at
all times
it was right after Destiny's rebellion
ugh it came right after a late night
drink it's where's his wood oh goodness
I'm having so much trouble today please
forgive me you lovely lovely you were so
beautiful people what oh my god am i
coughing up blood why am i call hi will
you just keep slapping your meat all the
way down the hallway I'm sure no one
will mind the Vice is broken I'd better
find one that works what is this device
oh hello I can climb up here which is a
good thing so am I going to get a light
source or am I going deaf
under around in the darkness I guess
okay it's a saw machine so am I supposed
to go towards that seems to have cut
that guy in half also why am i why am i
coughing up blood alrighty then
some as well to go in here for any
reason hello bunny I'm your nurse you
seem to be fine
judging by your heart rate so Oh stretch
let's stretch me that's some language
that I don't know about some word in the
Slovak language because this isn't made
by a guy in America I don't know if that
means it's gonna be better or worse hey
why don't I just start insulting people
in every country that's a great way to
kick off a series actually I don't think
there's gonna be all that long I think
it may be he said it was like 45 minutes
long so we'll see how about that tiny
box sim are you here oh well the music
got dramatic okay there seems to be a
wall here in the darkness tonight oh I
can take this oh cool this is weird
I never actually taken one of these
little candle things that actually had
light on him huh I wonder if I can get
in get in life vine okay that didn't
work but I did not see this box before
is there something in here that I need
another tea box does that stand for
tinder boxers are like a t-rex
prehistoric box so now that I have a
candle can I do something about that
strap it up okay number one I'm just
gonna move on assume that I got what I
came for Oh down here okay I didn't see
the before
ah rule check your mementos well I think
I shall the prison door is locked it is
important to find a key somewhere was
there a key in that box
coz there was a lock in that box I don't
know if that was also a key it's a
padlock some shrapnel of something or
other yeah I can't pull that out wait a
minute what the hell why can't I pull
that out that light does not help me
much at all okay so there's got to be a
key somewhere around here whoa don't
drop things willy-nilly come on hold on
to your sanity for just a little bit
longer I'm assuming I'm gonna need it so
there's nothing here well alright then
ah door did not see door got an open
door wow when I'm holding that thing the
controls go all kinds of wonky all right
whoa
that's not a good sign well I'm assume
also go to hell go to hell hi what the
hell is wrong with you where are you
moving okay I get it bad things happen
to you super health motion good god what
is wrong with you it's good good look at
your face there wherever the hell it is
Oh God your head's all backwards if you
didn't know your heads on backwards
don't know if you knew this buddy that's
a pretty sight okay alright alright so
anything in here
alright what is all this stuff a
prototype accumulator a tesla prototype
and another broken thing okay well I
thought that was out for a second there
okay it's out now since I got up let
that thing get up
oh that thing got up didn't it oh shut
up I knew it's gonna get up shut up I
got things to do yeah time for Texas out
on Iron Maiden I'm used to leave
no we did one now huh what do you want
now oh thank you thank you kind sir
whoa cello's shutters in the darkest
spiders let's go cockroaches I guess
okay let me just open the iron Minton
its product good idea oh there's a note
good oh wow all right then so where this
map was placed was in the Alpha cell
there's cell beta which I'm guessing is
where the guy got cut in half cell alpha
is where I am right now so I need to go
around to the intersection door to go to
pit cells four and five raisins and
Bulls I'm glad that used all the torture
chambers from the first amnesia game
that's that's awfully kind of them
let's do anything that's four ma'am
needs Justine okay hey anyone in no I'll
my eyes okay fine then let's be on my
way now that I got my key okay so I do
have a tinderbox but I don't want to use
it in this area just in case then what
are woodland creatures doing in a cave
like this some a natural yeah so I'll
have you got for me I have you got for
me yeah
Oh how am i low that uh rock cuz I'm
coughing up blood open this up oh sorry
my door stop of a candle came there I
tell you this thing that sings not easy
to hold I really hope this isn't my
lantern for the whole game all right
well that's locked down then again
woodland creatures not supposed to be in
this area oh boy I get to crawl through
the hole huh alright this bright dark
and scary and something's gonna pop out
at me Oh
bonesaw didn't help this guy much
personal note after being in prison none
of us was able to find out what this
place what is this place who are these
men and what are their plans one thing
is for sure staying here means certain
death
I was able to steal some torturing tools
I used it and escaped myself I
discovered a tunnel looks unstable but
there's no other way I must get the hell
out of this pit of death
well how ironical you died in a pit of
death so now that I got a saw Hey the
[ __ ] guru all right then well I'm okay
but we just popped in to say hi ask me
how I'm doing
do I need a snack oh no wait what ah
doesn't make any sense at all and why
did he have ragdoll huh arm sorry my
thing just spent
all righty then cuz I'm gonna make my
way out of here sooner than I thought
all right so I was waiting for me on the
other side
apparently I'm strong enough to rip that
right off its bars with a simple
torturing tool anybody here
okay so there's a weird combo technology
and old Miss to this place so I wonder
what's gonna happen next
that just light up when I walked in or
was it already lit yeah I'm going to the
prison oh hello what the hell is that
yeah that's like something straight out
of a creepypasta
I lost my light so I'm all but I'm
mounting I'm not gonna get another one
am i oh oh I did have a light oh it's a
Tesla prototype I didn't even know that
was my lantern alrighty then okay all
right let's see what you're dealing with
Susie no no no no I'm in a prison I'm a
prisoner I'm where I'm supposed to be
don't you dare don't you freaking dare
don't you dare oh god he's coming in any
it's okay I'm fine it's all good
first oh there's okay so he passed by
where I was so he's not gonna mind at
all when I go this way
correct correct what do I win what do I
win all right what else we got Hey okay
I was loud then again I did turn up my
volume on my ears again archived
literature according to general
information the brazen bull is one of
the most terrifying and cruel kind of
torturing and execution devices it was
designed in Greece the ancient letters
provide information that it was
constructed for cruel tyrant that is
provided proven by the fact that the
first victim of this invention was the
inventor himself during the
demonstration how does this device work
the ruler locked him inside and burned
the fire under the bull his screams were
going through the holes of the Bulls
nose and it did sound like an actual
bull there's no doubt that the death
inside the brazen wolf always one of the
most painful ways to die and not only
that it's an intimidation factor to
everyone who's able to listen to the
bull because they know what's going down
inside and they don't want any part of
it wait why why burn why why why no oh
god dammit dammit dammit dammit dammit
dammit dammit dammit dammit dammit [ __ ]
okay alright then alright then alright
I'll just lay here I'll go to bed where
I lay my head is home alright
oh no my head's way over there alright
whatever okay so he got me forgot that
he was patrolling didn't realize it was
gonna be a big ass circle so let's go
another way shall we
a derogation room is it the irrigation
room oh hi you're naked but Wilma hello
okay alright uh what am I supposed to
look at this I'm a nice what's okay let
me hey you let me shine a light on your
dick where are the other drugs going
we get real close to your face well yeah
okay so that guy doesn't want to talk to
me I'll just ignore that totally normal
whatever the first rule obey the rules
this conspiracy organization is strictly
based on system and obedience this
organization for conspiracies to
overthrow the government
the second rule discretion the existence
of this organization is only known by
156 individuals over the Europe most of
them being important members of
government religious organisations
aristocracy and military forces any
betrayal means capital punishment third
rule the purpose since 1678 the only
purpose of this place is getting rid of
uncomfortable persons those who know too
much those who are potential threats
those who stand in our way
also the Herald's the Liberals
revolutionaries fourth rule mode of
death the way of death and torturing
procedures are ordered by the clients
they determine the process and pay for
it everything is well organized files
are all the safety since the secret
conspiracy employs top scientists and
executioner's it is recommended to watch
for your own safety the results of
unsuccessful experiments are mostly
locked in forbidden areas but there's
risk that they may escape they may
recklessly attack you no matter who you
are sure glad you got all the
information in this secret organization
written on this piece of paper here why
that makes it really helpful for anyone
who doesn't want to know anything about
it mm-hmm key the machinery key the
prisoners subject right jex to unveil
the secret information in case one is
defying for too long the protocol is
clear the Chinese water torture longer
this method is applied the more its
victim loses its mind
that's horrible why don't you do that
maybe those tea boxes are actually Tesla
boxes I don't know
energy prototype emulators still don't
know what that's for oh maybe it's a
battery for the thing who knows who
knows these things you carry on mr.
individual you carry on mister sir I'm
assuming that the guy might be gone now
the monster that was chasing me although
he did kind of back me into a corner
which was totally unfair why is it blood
they're carrying on I got a machinery
key so quit crying we all got problems
Oh whiny baby over here okay it's way to
the machinery that's awfully nice for
the sign to say all of those words okay
what do we got kind of machinery you got
for me I won't forgive some of the
grammatical things because obviously
this was not made by probably a native
English speaker okay so that's weird
what's in here can I walk through there
probably not okay so I gotta go up here
alright the weight of the machinery sure
sucks I'm gonna pop out of me
so I'm gonna pop out of me don't know
why but some anything well hello
who are you
well okay the electricity was
successfully charged now the button
should work on the door should open one
button
what door I don't know okay can I jump
down I can indeed alright so mister man
ain't there that guy's mangled all hell
oh it's a dead brute I killed him I kill
them with my bare hands
I'm so tough okay so the button pardon
okay so the button should be somewhere
around here as well is that a button
that doesn't look like a button but
maybe it's a button in disguise much
like a robot in disguise okay no so
where's this button ball 10 or 10 button
where's the button well there a button
up there that I didn't see damn it
dagnabbit dagnabbit damn deadly
are you whispering it oh hi whoa alright
then
nice chair how's it going how's it
hanging alright then uh so nothing there
for me Oh blood 10 door ok did not see
before so where does this lead the
dungeon oh good good to know I'm not
oh god what's that I don't know if you
guys can see that it's like some demonic
HR Giger stuff very fancy all right nice
okay so either way I'm going to have to
end this episode here I know this game
isn't that long but I try to make into
even parts so thank you all so much for
watching click the annotation for more
videos that I've done and as always I
will see you in the next video bye
miron evil